- I smiled at the person, and I thought,
oh, like, he smiled back, he was nice.
And then I just felt
this person following me,
and this kind of, looming presence,
and he would not go.
It's just so sad,
because I feel like every woman
has a story, and that's why I
loved this storyline so much
because it brings out the other
female character's stories.
- So the inspiration for
Aimee's storyline in series two
came from a personal
experience that I had myself.
This thing happened to
me about five years ago,
where I was on my local bus
and I was on the way to
King's Cross station,
I was going to visit someone in Scotland.
It was really early in the morning
and I got on, and the thing
that was really strange about it
was that the bus was
actually basically empty,
except there was like one
other woman who was, like,
at the back of the bus.
And this man got on and
he just made a beeline,
like, straight for me,
and came and, like, sat right next to me,
which was just so weird,
where I was like, you have so many seats,
that you could sit on,
but you've come and you've
sat right next to me.
I had my bags on the floor,
and he put his feet on my bags,
so that, like, I couldn't move.
And he started, like,
kinda inching himself towards me,
and then he was like, sort
of, rubbing himself on me,
and then touching himself.
(rhythmic music)
♪ Talk about things you'd like to do ♪
- Sorry!
♪ You got to have a dream ♪
♪ If you don't have a dream ♪
♪ How you gonna make a dream come true ♪
- What you doing?
(man grunting)
He's wanking on me!
(passengers speaking faintly)
- I mean, I think everyone
knows this feeling,
but I just went into this, like,
it was like, fight or flight.
I just suddenly was like,
I have to get out of this situation,
like, I think this person means me harm,
like, I need to go.
And so I ended up, I just
like grabbed my stuff
and, like, I got off the bus.
It was so creepy because he moved,
he moved seats, so that he
could see me out the window.
Like, as the bus went off.
And I just burst into tears.
And then, it was really strange,
cause I kinda shook it off,
and like, got on with my, you
know, my weekend or whatever,
and then it just really stayed in my head,
and I started having
sort of panic attacks,
where, like, I couldn't
get back on my bus,
I didn't like getting on the Tube,
and this lasted for, sort
of like, weeks afterwards.
And in the end, the thing
that actually helped me,
was I was sort of part of
this like, feminist, sort of,
women's group on Facebook.
And I ended up, like,
posting a thing about it.
It was like way before any of
the me too stuff had happened.
And just hearing, like,
other women, sort of,
saying, oh, like, that happened to me,
and I totally understand
where you're coming from,
just made me feel, I don't know,
like more kind of heard,
and that gave me a bit
of, sort of, solace,
and I think, made me feel a bit braver.
- So about eight years
ago, I was on a bus,
I was on my way home quite late at night,
and I was on the phone to my mum.
And, really distracted,
and didn't really notice
the guy next to me
until I suddenly looked down
and realized that his hand was on my leg.
And I kind of froze in shock,
and before I could think,
or move, or do anything,
he moved his hand up and
grabbed me in the crotch,
groped me, grabbed me between the legs.
And I stood up, and I moved away from him,
and because I was on the phone,
I said what was happening out loud.
And I said,
"Mum, I'm on the bus, this
guy's just groped me."
And everybody on the bus heard,
and everybody looked away.
No one even made
- What?
eye contact with me,
they looked down at their
phones, or out the window,
no one said a word.
And it made me feel
panicked and embarrassed,
and like I shouldn't have said anything.
It was as if they had said,
they might as well have said,
whoa, don't bring this
up, you deal with this,
this is your thing.
Made me think, oh god, it
must have been my fault,
I was in the wrong
place at the wrong time,
or I was wearing the wrong thing.
I got off the bus, and I ran
the rest of the way home,
and I never told anyone what had happened.
And it was only later that I looked back
and realized it wasn't just me
that got such a strong message
from the people around us,
you know, this is your
problem, you deal with it,
this is normal.
It was also the man on the bus.
He learned you can be on a public bus,
you can sexually assault a woman,
you can have her say
what's happening out loud,
and no one will do a thing.
You can get away with
this, in other words,
go ahead, do it again.
It just happened to fall, for me,
in a week during which I had
a number of other incidents
of quite serious, being
followed home by a man
who just wouldn't leave me alone,
wouldn't take no for an answer,
being shouted at in the
street by some blokes
really commenting about my breasts.
And at the end of this week, I sat down
and I was thinking about it,
and it just suddenly hit me,
if those things hadn't all
happened in the same week,
I probably wouldn't have thought twice
about any one of them,
because it's normal.
And it just made me
suddenly have this moment
of thinking, why is this normal?
Why is it just the way things are?
I started talking to other
women and just saying,
for the first time ever,
have you ever had anything like this?
And the stories just poured out
of every woman I spoke to.
- Something remarkably
similar happened to me
on a train platform,
when I was really young.
I smiled at the person, and I thought,
oh, like, he smiled back, he was nice.
And then I just felt
this person following me,
and this, kind of, looming presence,
and he would not go.
And I was walking through crowds,
and I was thinking, my
mum always used to say,
"Try and find a family."
(all murmuring agreement)
Or somebody like that,
find a family and stand with them,
and say, I'm really sorry,
but I couldn't see any families.
I could only see other,
at that point it was like,
I could only see men.
I was like, why are there no women here?
And then I went over to
this guy, and I was like,
"Can I just walk with you?
Can I just walk with you?"
And he was kinda looking
at me like I was a freak,
and I knew this guy was like, yeah,
touching himself behind me,
walking down this train platform.
And that was the worst
part, was feeling ignored.
- Yeah
- And feeling like,
why does no one know,
why can no one see what's going on here?
And that's what I found so
moving in Aimee's storyline
was of course, the event
is so traumatizing,
but what traumatizes her even more
is that she has such faith in the world,
and she has such faith in people,
so when she's looking
round after it's happened
she really does expect someone to go,
I'll help you!
and nobody does, everyone's blank.
And that's the thing where it's like,
I used to feel so safe, and now I don't.
This man smiled at me, he had a kind face,
he didn't look like he
was capable of that.
How do I navigate in the world now?
Now that I know that I'm not safe,
and now that I know that
when I smile at someone,
it might invite that kind of behavior.
Can I get off the bus please?
(tense electronic music)
- Watch it with the case!
- Sorry!
(bell dings)
- Can I get off the bus please?
- You all right, love?
- Yeah.
I just need to get off the bus, please.
He jizzed on me.
- It can make you feel very vulnerable,
where you start blaming yourself,
or you can start to feel like, maybe,
you know, it was down to something
that you might have done or said.
- It's so good, I think, that you focused
on the reactions of the people
around Aimee on the bus.
Because we so often wrongly focus on
well, what did she do wrong?
And what could she have done?
And the truth is, if
any one of those people
had said something, or stepped in,
it would have made a huge difference.
It would have sent her the
message that it's not her fault,
and she's not alone,
and it's not normal and
just something that happens.
And it would have sent him the message,
you can't get away with this.
That's the most heartbreaking
thing about this scene,
the guy who does it gets the message,
this is okay, no one will challenge you,
you can go and do it again.
- I think we've all been in that situation
where you've seen something
happening, to another woman,
and there's a strange connection
where you sort of look at each other,
like when I was on the bus,
there was another woman on the bus,
and, you know, she looked at me like,
oh my god, this is awful,
but she also didn't jump in,
but it's like, I don't really expect her
to do that either.
But it's like, we need other men, I think,
to be saying, you know,
this is not right.
- I think Aimee is the perfect character
for this to happen to,
because she operates on
this plane of like trust,
and, you know, even with her mean friends,
she doesn't think they're bad people,
she just thinks the right thing to do now,
is to say, I'm gonna stand up for Maeve.
Cause Maeve needs me.
She's always kind of,
trying in her way to do the right thing,
and she doesn't really dislike
or hate or mistrust anyone.
So, this kind of, I keep
saying that she's like
the good witch in "The Wizard of Oz"
who's like, in the bubble.
- Yeah.
- That comes down,
and then all of a sudden
that bubble's just popped,
and she's like, crashed down to earth.
And it's like, she has
this identity crisis,
because it's, everything
I thought was true, isn't.
If I smile at someone, something
bad might happen to me.
If I'm nice to someone,
something bad might happen to me.
And she doesn't think she
deserves to be traumatized by it.
She keeps saying, it's not a big deal,
it's just a little stain,
it's not a big deal, it's not a big deal.
Because she feels like she doesn't deserve
to be blindsided by it.
So what do you wanna do for your birthday?
- Nothing.
What happened to this cake, exactly?
- It didn't look so bad before,
but then I was on the bus,
and a guy wanked on my leg,
and I got a bit of a shock,
and I smushed the cake.
- What?
- Do you think it'll stain?
I love these jeans.
- You have to report it.
- It's fine, they were only cheap.
- No, you've been assaulted.
- I think he was just lonely.
Or not right in the head or something,
which is weird, cause
he was quite handsome.
- Ames, this is serious.
- It's silly. I'm fine, honestly.
- Okay, I know what I want
to do for my birthday.
I want us to go to the police.
(uneasy music)
- So even when it's happening, she's like,
okay, this thing's happening to me,
which is really weird,
and I'm not sure why it's happening to me,
but I need to just take care of this cake,
and I need to get it to Maeve,
and if I can take care of this
and make sure she has a happy birthday,
then all that'll be fine,
and it'll just be,
and I feel like that is
such a female instinct.
It's, okay,
what do I need to do?
What's the next action that I need to do?
Rather than just stopping, going,
how did that make me feel?
Even though that is a
terrifying thing to do,
is actually to sit in the feeling,
and to get angry about it,
because anger isn't really
allowed if you're a woman.
You know, especially if
you're someone like Aimee,
who feels like her main
value is sweetness,
and kind of, easy breeziness, you know.
She thinks, oh I'm not,
you know, don't look at me,
I'm kind of, you know, I'm fine,
I'm just here, like, having a
nice day, I'm okay, I'm okay.
And if I'm not, if I'm
not that happy person,
then people won't wanna be around me.
But this thing's happened to me
that's made me actually angry, and sad,
and I don't like that,
and I don't like that it's
shifted my personality
because now I don't really
have anything to offer anymore.
And I don't know how to function now
that I'm the one who needs support.
And that's why she
really isolates herself,
because I think she thinks,
well, I'm just gonna be a pain,
if I'm around people with
this negative energy,
I'm just gonna be a burden.
So I'll just kind of remove
myself from everyone.
And I slate myself, and I think
that's what we all do, as well,
cause we are taught to
accommodate from such young age.
It's like, if you're gonna be a bit sad
and a bit, kind of, of a negative Nelly,
why don't you just kind of, you know,
keep yourself to yourself?
(all murmuring agreement)
You know, cause you don't wanna
upset anyone.
- Don't take up space.
- And you don't wanna take up that space,
yeah, that's exactly what it is.
And I think this trauma forces
her to start taking up space
because she can't not.
It's like this thing that
wants to rip out of her.
- [Maeve] Anything about me!
- [Ola] You don't know anything about me!
- Stop fighting over a stupid boy!
- Ames, why are you crying?
- (whimpers) Because I
can't get on the bus.
It was really difficult
to go back to that time
of being 17 or whenever,
but that's because I'm
older and I've matured
and I know that I'm allowed
to be a multi-faceted human being
who experiences a range of emotions,
and I don't have to just be
a sweet, digestible woman.
So I would permit myself
to get angry, now.
Back then, it was going
back into that mindset
of I'm not allowed to feel this way.
I need to just suck it
up and get on with it.
- You're so right about that being
something we're taught
to perform as women.
Being polite, not making a fuss.
One of the first girls
that I ever worked with
on this particular topic
was a 14 year old girl
who'd been sexually assaulted on a bus,
and the man that did it had
followed her off one bus
and onto the next, and
she felt uncomfortable,
and she knew it was weird,
but she was only 14 years
old, and she'd been taught
that she shouldn't be rude to grown-ups.
- Exactly.
- And so when he sat down next to her,
and started talking to her,
she felt like she had to answer.
And she'd also been taught
that she shouldn't make a fuss,
and she shouldn't, kind
of, get in people's way.
So when he started touching her,
she didn't want to say anything,
cause she didn't want to disturb
the people around her on the bus.
And at 14, that girl had been taught,
as a girl, you need to be quiet,
not get in the way, not make a fuss,
you need to be polite.
But no one had ever thought to teach her,
no one has the right to touch
you without your consent.
And we don't, we teach
women, like you say,
this is normal, this is part of life.
What were you doing,
were you asking for it?
What were you wearing when it happened?
Well, you were probably flirting.
Maybe he just liked you.
All of the reasons that we have.
Are you overreacting?
Are you sure that's really what happened?
Did you imagine it?
Are you sure he was touching you?
Especially in a crowded bus
where it so often happens.
How can you be sure that's
really what was going on?
Surely someone would have said something
if you really said what was happening?
We have so many different
ways to tell women,
don't say anything,
maybe it was your fault,
did it even really happen at all?
Is it any wonder that
we don't talk about it?
- I think that thing about
not making a, like, scene,
not wanting to disrupt other people,
I feel like, I'm 33 now, and I
feel like that's still in me,
on some level.
- Always!
(all murmuring agreement)
- Conditioning, isn't it?
- So conditioned,
it's so buried.
- I mean, I even had that
when I first started
wearing a skirt at school.
I always wore trousers,
I was such a tomboy,
and then the first time I wore a skirt
was when I was 15.
And it was summer, like, that was why.
And I got called up, and taken out,
where my headteacher told me off.
She was a woman, and she told
me off for wearing a skirt.
And I was like, why?
She was like, oh because
we've got male teachers
running the playground.
And I was like, I was also
just like, so confused,
I was like, I don't understand how,
but she was like, Mr. So-and-So's
just said your skirt's too short.
I was like, why was he looking at--
- Exactly!
- What?
- I don't understand--
- The message that that gives.
- The child wearing the skirt
isn't the problem in that scenario--
- Yeah, do you know what I mean?
- It's the adult--
- Cause he couldn't control his feelings.
- Right, so I'm so confused,
like whose best interests do we have?
We need to be on side of our girls, like,
and stop this,
actually--
- And not teach them.
- Yeah.
- That it's normal, cause if
that happened to you at school
and then you're in a
bus a few years later,
you're thinking, well this
is what I learned at school,
this is my fault.
- Absolutely.
- I'm wearing the wrong thing.
- Did you have a low top on?
- I'm bringing it on--
- Yeah.
- You know, even talking about
feeling like you couldn't smile at people,
you were made to feel
like it was your fault
for smiling at him,
of course it wasn't your
fault for smiling at him,
but that's what
the world tells us--
- Why did you engage?
Why did you engage in it?
- Right?
I must have done
something to deserve this.
- Yeah.
- I like that you focused on this,
because I think often when
we talk about sexual assault,
it's such a big spectrum, right,
it feels like something very,
very explicitly intimate
is happening, in a very public place.
Often a lot of people don't think
they can even get help
for something like this.
Like Aimee's character.
(melancholy music)
- See, she's got a proper problem.
- You've got a proper problem.
- Pot hole on the high street.
Bloody council.
- Come on, let's go,
it's basically like he
sneezed on me or something.
- He came on you, Aimee, yeah?
- Yeah, cum is kind of like
a penis having a sneeze.
Ugh, that means when you
swallow someone's cum,
it's like eating their snot.
- [Officer] Just take a seat,
we'll be with you in a bit.
Hi there, how can I help you?
- Hi.
This is my friend Aimee.
She got sexually assaulted on the bus.
- I got jizz on my jeans.
I mean, we're probably wasting your time.
- You're not wasting
anyone's time, all right?
- That scale you talked
about, that spectrum,
where we're told it's okay to talk about
very serious forms of sexual offenses,
but we shouldn't talk about others.
We don't do that with
anything else, right?
Nobody says the police should
never tackle any fraud cases
until they've solved all the murders.
- Right.
- With everything else, we accept
that there are different
things that happen
and no one's saying they're all the same,
but they're all completely
valid to tackle,
except with this,
except when we're trying to
shut women up, basically.
- I think it cuts
through a lot of bullshit
when something like this happens.
And it can really show
you what's important.
To sort of say, I'm sorry
that happened to you,
and the girls say it to each other,
and it was very moving.
And I mean, it's a very small moment,
but it's that idea of
having someone acknowledge
that you've been through
something absolutely terrible.
- Yeah.
- And also to show, sort
of, how you can help someone
who's been in that situation.
- Yeah, like, not trying
to fix it, necessarily.
- Yeah!
- Like, just matching it.
- Just being like,
I hear you.
That's awful.
- Just listen to them.
- [Laura] Yeah.
- And all of these girls
can sit there in a room
they don't have anything to talk about,
they're not friends normally,
and yet this is the one thing
that they can all bond over.
- [Viv] So you can't get on the bus
because you think that
man's gonna be on it again?
- No, it's more that he
had this really kind face.
I remember, because he smiled at me.
And he didn't look like
some wanking psycho killer.
So it's like, if he could
do something like that,
then anyone could.
I always felt safe
before, and now I don't.
Probably sounds stupid.
- It doesn't sound stupid.
I was groped at the
train station last year.
We were going to a gig in the city,
this groups of guys walked past,
and one of them grabbed my tit.
(men laughing and jeering)
And it really, really hurt.
So I sometimes feel funny in crowds too.
It was like they thought my
body was theirs, or something.
- Yeah, like we're public property.
- A few years ago, some
boys were catcalling me.
- [Boy] Nice!
This woman told me it was my fault
because my shorts were too revealing.
- [Woman] You have to be
careful, dressing like that.
So I went home and I
cut them even shorter.
Because fuck them.
- Good, why should you have
to change your behavior
because of what they did?
- [Maeve] Exactly.
- I used to go to the local swimming pool
all the time when I was a kid.
One day, this guy flashed
me his penis in the pool.
And it looked all dangly
and funny under the water.
(young Viv giggling)
I told my mum about it,
and she wouldn't let me go back anymore.
It's sad, because the pool
was my favorite place to go.
- That's so unfair.
- I guess, but statistically,
two thirds of girls
experience unwanted sexual
attention or contact
in public spaces before the age of 21.
So, it's not unusual.
- A man followed me home
from work about a year ago.
Every time I sped up, he sped up.
(keys jangling)
It was so scary.
(tense music)
He ran off when he saw my dad,
which made me angry,
because I don't want to be
dependent on another man
to protect me.
- I'm sorry that happened to you.
- You too.
- Thank you.
You're so right about that I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, rather than
doing, like, detective work,
and saying, so when did you move away?
And did you say this thing to him?
- Yeah.
- And did you try and give the message
that you didn't want him?
There's no questions asked, it's just,
I hear you and I'm sorry.
- I'm sorry that happened to you,
yeah.
- And that can be the most
relieving thing when you feel like
you don't have to explain yourself,
and give any disclaimers,
or give any justifications,
it's just, this is what happened,
and someone just saying,
cause it does feel like,
at that moment, that person
is taking a little bit
of that pain away from you.
Because they're saying,
I'm sorry and I see it.
- I see you.
- I see it, and I see you,
and it's real.
- Yeah.
- I believe you.
- [Aimee] I believe you.
- And it's like, just the
release of telling somebody,
you know, and having someone
listen to you properly,
and that release does make it,
I think it does make
it a little bit easier,
cause it then makes it more like,
it's not my fault that it happened,
and all of the other 50% of the, like,
I call them vampires,
you know the voices in your head
that chat shit, and sort of,
are just, sort of, always going,
oh no but it's your fault.
- Yeah, yeah.
- What did you do?
Whatever, you can cut half of that
when you tell someone and
they just listen to you.
- Sort of relief.
- Like, you can stop
so much of that anxiety,
and so much of your own,
I don't know, self-hate,
or self-blame, or whatever,
which I think comes hand in hand with it.
And it's something that has
to be acknowledged as well.
- Yeah.
- Probably a lot of my
friends that I talk to,
that have been through
something like this,
the hardest bit is telling someone.
- So, fair hair, clean shaven,
five feet eight or nine,
and a blue jacket.
- It was kind of aqua.
- And was he already on the bus?
- Yeah.
I think so.
He might have got on at the second stop.
- Right, it's really important to know
what stop he got on at,
so we can get as clear
a picture as possible.
So you said, you remember smiling at him,
was that after the first
stop, or the second?
- Sorry, what's that
got to do with anything?
Are you saying she shouldn't
have smiled at him?
- Look, charges like this
are really hard to convict.
And if we do actually catch the guy,
the questions are gonna get harder.
- Can I have my jeans back please?
I'm gonna go, I'm sorry to make a fuss.
- Ames.
What if he does it to someone else?
I know you can do this.
Please.
- You're doing brilliantly, Aimee.
- [Maeve] Yeah.
- Just, take your time.
Try to remember.
- He was already on the bus.
- I've really noticed
a difference as well,
since me too and all of
those kind of conversations
have really been brought
out into the open.
Like, I feel like I used to
talk to my female friends
about stuff like that,
but it would almost be
in a jokey kind of way?
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
- And they--
- Funny anecdote for you.
- Yeah, and now I feel like it's like,
oh, it's okay to take this seriously.
- I had that once, where
I worked with somebody
that just used to slap me on the bum.
But because I started working there
when I was 16, I genuinely
thought it was okay.
I said it to someone as a joke,
and they were like, that's bad
that that's happened to you.
- Oh it's the most--
- By the way.
- And I've noticed, yeah, a lot recently,
where there's that shift of,
oh my god, hilarious story,
the creepiest guy, so.
And then someone just
goes, that's not funny.
It's completely wrong.
And I think the fear when
Aimee finally opens that box up
and she gets sad, and she gets angry,
and yet the girls still like her.
- Oh, out of curiosity,
what did you come up with?
What binds you together?
- Other than non-consensual
penises, miss, not much.
(dramatic music)
- You gonna be okay?
- I think so.
I don't feel sad, I just feel angry.
- I know something that might help.
- Now that I've just
taken that leap of faith,
and been vulnerable, and
shown a side of myself
that maybe Aimee has
thought, up until now,
that that's kind of,
like, an unattractive,
or, like, displeasing side of her.
And then when she finally, kind of,
can't do it anymore because
she's just so exhausted,
and so overwhelmed, and so triggered,
and then she lets this part of herself out
that she's kind of pushed down so much,
and the girls are like,
no, we're with you.
- Yeah.
- Let's go fucking smash some shit.
- Let's go smash.
Let's find that rage.
- Let's do it.
- Come on.
- And I'm gonna cheer for you
while you do it.
What do I do?
- Think about something that
makes you really, really angry,
and then smash it as hard as you can.
- I'm angry that I'm not
very good at baking cakes.
(glass shattering)
- Yes!
- Woo!
- Come on!
- Go on, Aimee!
(uplifting music)
- I'm angry that Steve
keeps trying so hard
to make things better,
but he doesn't understand.
(glass smashing)
(girls cheering and clapping)
- I'm angry that a horrible man
ruined my best jeans
and nobody did anything,
and now I can't get on the fucking bus!
(girls cheering)
- This is amazing!
(girls whooping)
Can I keep smashing stuff?
- Yes!
- Give it to them!
♪ But you gotta ♪
♪ Make your own kind of music ♪
♪ Sing your own special song ♪
♪ Even if nobody else sings along ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
- When I started talking about it,
people said to me, no sexism
doesn't exist anymore.
Woman are equal now.
- Who the fuck said that?
- This problem, it's
harder to imagine it now
with the conversation we're having,
which is great, but at
the time, eight years ago,
people said, you know,
women are equal now,
you're making a fuss about nothing.
You know, you're looking for problems.
And I thought, we can't fix this problem
if people don't know it exists.
We're all experiencing it,
we've all got these stories,
but no one even knows
they're happening to us,
so maybe one way to try and move forward
would be to bring these
stories out into the light.
- I agree.
- And I set up this project
called "The Everyday Sexism Project."
It started out as a
website, and I just said,
if anyone's got an experience
they want to share,
someone of any gender,
anywhere on that spectrum,
from low-level sexist, sexual harassment,
all the way up to discrimination or abuse,
and I thought, maybe if 40 or
50 people share their stories,
we'll be able to say look,
this is still happening,
you can't dismiss all of us,
we weren't all getting
the wrong end of the stick
or making it up.
And I thought that maybe then
we could take it seriously.
And actually what happened
was that within months,
thousands of stories had poured in.
Within the first couple of years,
we had 100,000 stories.
- Jesus.
- Oh god.
- Now there are hundreds
and hundreds of thousands,
and suddenly we had this data set
that was the largest of its kind
that had ever been collected.
And I thought, how could we use this
to try and stop these things happening
to other women in the future?
So we took the stories we collected
about really specific things
and instead of saying, as we so often do,
well what did she do about that?
Or what can women do?
I took those stories, and I
put them in front of the people
who could change things.
So we took the stories that
were just from girls at school
and took them into schools,
and took them to the government, and said,
we need sex and relationships education,
this has got to be on the curriculum,
cause look what's happening.
- Yeah.
- Obviously really
relevant to the show, like.
Kids didn't know that
it was sexual assault.
I didn't know when it happened.
No one had ever given me that language
to know that what was happening to me
was against the law,
cause I'd just been taught
it's the way things are.
And we had thousands of stories
that had just come from women
on buses and tubes and
trains, public transport,
so we took them to the
British Transport Police.
They knew that there was a problem,
because they knew that at that time,
only about 10% of incidents of
sexual offenses on transport
were ever being reported.
But they didn't really
know how to tackle it,
because people weren't talking
about what was happening.
- Yeah.
- And we had all the stories,
thousands of them, but
no way to change things.
So we brought those two things together,
and we used those stories specifically
and those women's words
to retrain about 2,000 British
Transport Police officers
as part of a thing they launched
called Project Guardian.
And it meant that, suddenly, they realized
why people didn't feel like
they could talk about it.
They realized that if you tell your story,
and someone dismisses
it or doesn't believe it
when you first come forward,
you'll never ever feel like
you can come forward again.
And it really overhauled the way in which
the British Transport Police
dealt with sexual offenses
on public transport.
- It's incredible.
- And raised the reporting rates
and the detection of
offenders by about 25 or 30%.
So it was just a way to try
and not just have it be
about telling stories,
but actually telling stories
in itself is so powerful.
We hear from so many people who say,
until I found this website,
I thought I was alone.
I never told anyone what happened to me,
because I thought it was my fault.
Sometimes women in their 80s and 90s
who've carried the pain of what
happened to them for years,
and suddenly they see these
other women's stories,
and it's like this lifting,
this moment of thinking,
it's not just me, it wasn't my fault,
it's not okay, it's not the
way that things should be.
- That the girls and
boys need to understand
these boundaries,
and we need to talk about sex in a way
that it's actually happening.
And educate ourselves so that
we don't hurt each other.
- Yes, and at the moment we don't.
There's nothing on the
curriculum at the moment
that we have to talk about sexual consent,
anything apart from biology.
- So then we're teaching
boys that this is okay--
- That it's normal.
- You see what I'm saying?
So we're teaching them that
this is a completely normal thing,
and then they go on feeling entitled,
then when they do do something like that
and they do something wrong,
put someone in a situation,
they don't even know they've done it,
and they're so blase.
It can literally, as you
say, ruin someone's life.
And it can be stopped--
- I think that's why
language is so important,
like I think that thing about,
what you said when you were like,
oh I've been sexually assaulted.
I found it, even when I
was writing the script,
like, there was a moment where,
I can't even actually remember
if it ended up in the episode,
it might have been cut out,
but there was a moment
where Aimee says, like,
I've been sexually assaulted.
And even as I wrote it, there
was a little thing in my head
where I was like, oh, like, has she?
You know, cause it feels so heavy.
- [Laura] Yeah.
- And then you're like, yes.
- Yeah.
- That is exactly what it is.
And like, that's the language
that needs to be used.
Not just, oh, he was
a bit of a creepy guy,
or that was a bit of a--
- Absolutely,
or groping.
- Yes.
- That's the euphemism we used, right?
We say groping, cause we don't
like to say sexual assault.
- Yeah.
- Because people tell us
it's not that big a deal.
- Yes.
- I think for a lot of girls,
if they went to their friends
and said, I've been sexually assaulted,
and then described that scenario,
like friends, even, would say,
why were you being so melodramatic?
That's not a sexual assault.
Because we don't know,
we grow up thinking oh,
this is just normal.
And it's normal cause it
starts from such a young age.
We know that nearly,
just under one in three
16 to 18 year old girls experience
unwanted sexual touching at school.
In other words, about a
third of teenage girls
are sexually assaulted at school.
And if it starts then, then
where do you go from there?
If it's happened at school
where you should be safe--
- It's not good.
- It's just so much more
common than we'd like to think
from such a young age,
and if we don't talk about
it cause we're uncomfortable,
then we don't give
those girls the language
to name what's happening to them,
we don't give them the power
to know that they can object,
and like you said, we
don't teach boys to know
what their rights and responsibilities are
in navigating relationships either.
So everyone's confused.
- Yeah.
- And it just doesn't help anyone.
- I think when you realize
that it's like every woman that you know,
it's almost like a, sort of,
like you're breaking out of
some kind of psychosis or something,
where you're like, oh!
- You're not alone.
- Yeah, it's not just me.
- We're all just
living with this.
- We haven't talked about it.
- And we're not really talking
about it, or saying anything.
- And it's so important, I
think, that this storyline
really looks at the
long-term impact that it has.
Because so often, these
incidents are dismissed,
it's not a big deal,
like surely that's not that big a deal?
It was just a one off,
whatever people say,
and the truth is, just
like Aimee discovers,
it affects your whole life.
It affects how you feel,
how you feel about yourself,
how you feel in crowds,
amongst other people,
where you can go.
- Relationships.
- How you can get there,
your relationships.
(strident rhythmic music)
- What are you doing here?
- Getting the bus.
We're all getting the bus.
- [Bus Driver] Are you
getting on, or what?
- Give her a minute.
It's just a stupid bus.
- It's just a stupid bus.
- And we've just dismissed these stories,
and ignored them for so long,
and finally I think, women
and girls are speaking out,
and it's the power of
that collective voice.
One of us speaking out on our own,
we get shot down, we get
ignored, we get dismissed,
but when a whole group
of us stand together,
as Aimee's friends stand alongside her,
and say, this isn't okay,
we're not taking this shit anymore,
this has happened.
It forces people to
stop and listen to them,
and hopefully it forces us
to change the conversation,
and to really confront the idea
that this shouldn't just be normal.
- Yeah.
- It should be,
we've all been there, let's talk about it,
this needs to fucking change.
Because we shouldn't have all been there.
(indie music)
♪ Halfway up the street ♪
♪ I used to be free ♪
♪ I used to be 17 ♪
♪ La la la la la la la ♪
♪ La la la ♪